thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
dr. quest the pleasure please call me
Benton and may I call you mr. Brewster
Birdman okay is it Harvey Birdman or is
it Harvey Birdman I always thought it
was Birdman growing up like the
superhero but upon reflection I thought
it was a play on words like a person's
last name it seems like they're using
both here and I have no idea which one
it is I think as you can tell bird law
is not my specialty hey legal eagles
it's time to think like a lawyer and
today I am excited to be covering Harvey
Birdman attorney at law highly requested
and I used to watch this all the time as
a kid so I'm really excited to see how
this holds up as a practicing lawyer
this is actually going to be the first
in a couple of cartoon trials that I'm
going to cover let me know what you
think the next one is going to be
because I'm really excited about the
next one it's one of my absolute
favorites as always be sure to comment
in the form of an objection which I will
either sustain or overrule and stick
around until the end of the video where
I give Harvey Birdman a grade for legal
realism so without further ado let's dig
into the first episode of Harvey Birdman
attorney at law okay so the setup for
this episode is that the two father
figures in I think it's Jonny Quest are
having a dispute and the person who is
not Jonny quests father is taking off
with the two boys and wants paternity of
the two of them much to the chagrin of
their scientist father
I don't know Benton I guess I think of
the boys is my own of course you do race
you're like a second father to them what
if that's not good enough
being the second father I'm afraid I
don't catch your meaning I want the boys
Benton full time I've raised them and I
think it's only fair race you're tired
the adventure of the Yeti snow princess
took a lot out of both of us take a
couple of days oh oh I'm taking the boys
Benton and there's not a damn thing you
do about it that's definitely assault
and battery forgot my keys
Oh potential theft of the car Harvey
Birdman attorney at law dictating on his
fourteenth 2:34 p.m. dictating dictating
Harvey Birdman okay so this is actually
hilarious because it's has a kernel of
truth back in the day really just a
couple of years before I started
practicing it was fairly common for
attorneys to take dictation so they
would record their thoughts on to some
sort of reel-to-reel tape or a little
micro cassette or if you were really
fancy directly onto a computer and then
you would have your legal secretary
transcribe all of that and if they were
a really good legal secretary then they
would turn that into the basis for a
pleading or a letter to opposing counsel
and this is exactly what it would look
like and often you would have these
large gaps in the tape where you were
waiting to think of what else to say and
for this particular thing
sadly using dictaphones has gone out of
favor and now we just type everything
because most lawyers I think can type
faster than they can actually talk so
you really would not save any time doing
this but this is totally accurate to
what it used to be back in the day yes a
doctor quest to see you mr. Bergner and
any mean request the pleasure please
call me Benton and may I call you mr.
Birdman okay is it Harvey Birdman or is
it Harvey Birdman I always thought it
was Birdman growing up like the
superhero but upon reflection I thought
it was a play on words like a person's
last name it seems like they're using
both here and I have no idea which one
it is I think as you can tell bird law
is not my specialty what makes mr.
Benton believe he has any claim on your
children well I hired him to look after
the boys but as time went on he became
more a second father to them I said I'm
a good
but maybe I should have made more the
cat's in the cradle and the silver ball
I'll take the case but first I need to
speak to the boys what are their names
oh of course
their names certainly well uh yes well
there's a blond one the blond one whose
name is oh dear God there are certain
procedures that you can do to remove
custody of children away from their
biological parents it's very very
difficult to do but you can imagine if
the father did not actually know the
names of the children that would be
probably prima facie evidence that he
should not have custody over these
children or putting them in very
dangerous situations like playing with
explosives so you have enough on this
one one minute I'm a penniless orphan
stuck in his street-sweeping cast the
next I'm on this really cool needle II
plane that goes very very fast drinking
cold American beverages I owe dr. quest
very much big time then you Hey you know
he's my dad yes that was the onus on
August the results were negative thank
you so this is really good
Harvey Birdman or Birdman whichever it
is in this particular episode is doing a
good job of interviewing the prospective
witnesses that would be very important
when you're dealing with a custody suit
like this and it would be important for
any trial so you actually really don't
see witness prep going on very often in
dramas so good job to this cartoon for
actually getting one of the mundane
parts of the legal practice correctly
oh man Birdman at last we meet again
yeah I think it probably goes without
saying that obviously you can't walk
into court wearing a bird suit and a
mask
indogene oh and fun fact wearing a mask
in public is considered loitering under
New York law well Turo it was last week
I was in Zurich last week to knit
Avenger my personal digital assistant um
how do you make a tea again do you push
that and then leave it down or do I said
I'd live on to defeat you and that
happens this very day feel the power
oh my god the power of attorney the
power of attorney so super powers
notwithstanding it's actually pretty
common for attorneys in specific niches
like family law to know each other very
very well even in big cities there
aren't that many well-known family law
attorneys so if you dabble in that area
with some frequency you're gonna get to
know everyone else in the in the family
law bar and so it makes total sense that
Harvey Birdman knows this other person
even if he I think in the background is
a super villain as well and also true
story when you pass the bar you gain the
power of attorney which allows you to
shoot electricity and energy out of your
briefcase and hands the power of
attorney should not do that for the
judge because someone is the genetic
parent of a child does that make him the
one most fit to raise a child
please never judge there we shouldn't
have people in the quest family these
two adorable young boys okay
so a couple things going on here
obviously the attorney should not be
that close to the jury you can't enter
the well without permission or the
bailiff will tackle you especially in a
court surrounded by super villains and
superheroes other than that though
I will say that sometimes the attorneys
accents can make it very very difficult
to understand them and I will say that
when I was practicing in a very very
rural part of Virginia there were times
when I could not understand what the
opposing attorney was saying so you know
sometimes that happens and the attorney
might not know that he or she is losing
the jury because what he or she is
saying is totally incomprehensible that
definitely happens state your first name
your last name and occupation lizard man
lizard man and lizard man you witnessed
sure from what I saw
during a mystery of the lizard man is
mystery lizard man right right you know
from what I saw it was mr. Bannon who
was with the children the most thank you
hey good going bill nice job next
witness now what is my intelligence in
your opinion who the best parent is sure
quest was there physically but it was
clear to me that Bannon was the primary
caregiver best pattern Bannon mr. Bannon
now normally this kind of parade of
ridiculous witnesses is totally totally
illegitimate see for example the
Seinfeld trial where they just bring in
character witness after character
witness totally ridiculous it was a
communist now she exposed her nipple
mm-hmm
but here these witnesses actually are
not testifying to the character per se
but to the parenting ability of the two
adults in question I think all of this
testimony probably would come in and is
probative
in other words relevant to the crucial
question of whether the children are in
danger and whether custody should be
given over to the other person so there
should be some cross-examination going
on Harvey Birdman should be up and
cross-examining these people but all in
all the regular testimony is pretty good
boy that went well today I'd say as
celebrations in order sketch sketch
sketch classic Stan there 11
okay of course it's ridiculous to have
the children in a bar oh that does feed
into the idea that their father is not a
good caretaker I will say that after a
day of trial the place you were most
likely to find a lawyer is at a bar
probably the one that's closest to the
courthouse I'd like to call to the stand
dr. Benton quest dr. quest
tell us a little about your relationship
well way too close
way too close to the witness race and I
met one night with your boys oh right I
treasure them I love them dearly mm-hmm
that's technically improper you're not
allowed to lead the witness that way and
it's really damning for his case and
when I'm not working on my projects like
a way of accelerating particles to
subsonic speed using just magnets for
instance waveforms constant rates
nothing resolving the sum which
surprisingly equals the mass of the atom
and separating them by weight we should
see sometimes it is so hard to control a
witness and they think they're doing a
good job or they could just get lost in
whatever point that they're trying to
make whether it's good for the trial or
not yeah I feel for Harvey Birdman here
it's hard to control a witness sometimes
vision Botero
your witness spend time with your boys
why yes I think I have young times
entering watch things that a father does
with his son would include well
would you mind Jonny and [ __ ] know how
to play baseball why I'm not sure so
here you might think that the the policy
of never asking a question a
cross-examination that you don't already
know the answer to is sacrosanct but
this is actually a good example of when
you should deviate from that rule
because there's really no answer that
dr. quest can give here that will be
good
obviously the attorney knows that this
guy doesn't know his children very well
and if he answers the question correctly
well that he knows whether his children
know how to play baseball
or not well you just move on to the next
question without really any damage being
done however if the doctor fails to
answer the question in the way that he
is clearly failing to do here then he
will have played into the hands and that
testimony will be devastating to dr.
quests case so this is actually a good
example of asking questions you might
not necessarily know the answer to ahead
of time but it can lead to some really
really good and damning testimony look I
don't know why bases ball means so much
to everyone there's important work to be
done to make things more decent more
decent than baseball dun dun
that would be argumentative how long
have you known the boys why four years
almost half their lives and how would
you describe your relationship with them
on their body guard and tutor this would
also be improper because this attorney
has already called all of his witnesses
and then turned it over to the quests
presumably the respondent or the
defendant so you don't get to then call
new witnesses you'd be allowed to call
rebuttal witnesses but this is your main
witness so he's not a rebuttal witness
so that order of the witnesses is
totally wrong but you see this in a lot
of legal shows where they call witnesses
out of order to make it more dramatic
you know Harvey Birdman is no exception
this doesn't seem like race mm-hmm what
do the boys mean to you they mean they
mean everything to me
excuse me I've taught them how to
summer boats how to tie a tourniquet but
they've taught me so much more they've
taught me to care to nurture and I don't
see why a simple thing like biology
should get in the way of what I know in
my heart to be true thank you you're all
witness I was really good direct
testimony and really good open any
questions from the lawyer eliciting a
great narrative and some great sound
bites from the witness so great job with
direct examination bootylicious yes your
honor your witness
yes your honor mr. bannon how long have
you known the boys why four years almost
half their died as an aiding tell me mr.
Bennett what do you have to say about
this sorry yeah you're not allowed in
the well oh let's see no I tried that
one already what do you have to say
about this mr. bird man you better have
a damn good explanation for this I do
your honor
a few months ago during the adventure of
the sunken safe-deposit box race
mysteriously became left-handed and his
shoes suddenly had laces went up till
then they'd always been slip ons see the
bartender the game race a drugged frozen
lime daiquiri during the house and
tasteful men was the same man who judged
later dinged your Lexus and drove off
without exchanging insurance information
this man created a robot race Bannon and
programmed it to get the boys and that
man your honor is in this very courtroom
okay putting aside the theatrics of a
robot taking the stand that information
should have come out in discovery and
not in trial itself so if Harvey Birdman
was a good lawyer he would have
discovered all of this information
months ahead of the trial itself that's
what litigation is for stenographer read
back when I just said yes and that is
totally accurate that he could ask the
stenographer the court reporter to read
back part of the transcript in those
particular circumstances that's really
funny Oh drat this confounded machine
doesn't make any sense doctor dr. Zin
why was dr. Zin a stenographer though
picked a
valchek craft you know if the lawyer was
complicit with the supervillains
attempts to get custody of the boys and
suborned perjury and this false witness
that guy could get disbarred god it's so
good I love Harvard man I hope you guys
like this cuz I'd love to do another
episode to this it is time to give
Harvey Birdman attorney at law a grade
for legal realism so on the one hand you
have some pretty good trial tactics good
direct examination reasonably
cross-examination tactics and some
testimony that was actually relevant to
the question at hand which you actually
don't see all that often on the other
hand you have an abbreviated time frame
that is totally unrealistic you've got
superheroes and super powers going off
in the courtroom and some totally
ridiculous nonsense with some robots and
testimony but all in all I have to say
this is one of the more accurate
cartoons when you give it a discount for
trying to be a comedy and a kids show so
I will give Harvey Birdman attorney at
law a b-plus for legal accuracy you can
really feel the power of attorney the
power of attorney now whether you are a
superhero turned attorney or just want
to look good you need a quality
custom-made suit if you're looking for
an awesome slim cut suit I can't
recommend endo Chino highly enough I was
actually turned on to endo Chino by my
college dorm mate Nelson Young who's
probably the most fashionable guy I know
all of my suits are now made by
Indochina including this gray to button
that I'm wearing right now which was
custom made for me by endo Chino see the
secret to a great suit is all about the
fit I'm a reasonably athletic guy and I
can never buy suits off the rack because
they just simply never fit right if the
shoulders fit the waist is too small if
the waist is right I'll bust out of the
sleeves but with endo Chino you can send
it your measurements online or you can
go to one of their stores and have a
stylist take your measurements when I
wanted my first Indochina suit I had
made an appointment went to the store in
person and a stylist worked with me for
over 90 minutes to take all of my
measurements a couple of weeks later I
got the best fitting suit of my entire
life and the best part is I never had to
take my measurements again it was
perfect right out of
but if it wasn't they would have altered
it for me for free Indo cheetah will
make you a fully custom suit tailored
specifically for you for less than $400
and the best part is they still use the
best materials like super 130 or 140
wool and cashmere in fact I asked Indo
Chino to give legal eagles specifically
the best possible deal and they're
giving you guys the ability to buy any
premium suit for just 359 that is the
best deal you will find anywhere on
their premium suits I will never buy an
off-the-rack suit again and once you try
it neither will you legal eagles can get
any premium Indo Chino suit for just
three hundred and fifty nine dollars
when you enter the promo code legal
eagle at checkout or use the link in the
description using the promo code or the
link really helps out this channel
that's Indo Chino comm promo code legal
eagle for the best custom suit of your
entire life do you agree with my grade
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist for all of
my other real lawyer reactions over here
where I will see you in court